[Música]
mis compatriotas estadounidenses hoy con
un corazón lleno de gratitud y optimismo
ilimitado acepto orgullosamente esta
nominación para la presidencia de eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
misión la administración de mi esposo no
va a dejar de luchar hasta que exista un
tratamiento efectivo o una vacuna
disponible para todos every bank
donaldson o donald no va a descansar
hasta que haya hecho todo lo que se
puede para cuidar a todos los impactados
por esta terrible pandemia
[Música]
y déjenme ser claro la violencia debe
parar ya sea en minneapolis portland o
king o ya tendremos ley orden en las
calles de este país para cada
estadounidense de cada raza credo y
color
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a china le han quitado la cortina a las
prácticas del partido comunista les ha
hecho rendir cuentas por el virus chino
y por la destrucción económica en eeuu y
el mundo y no se quedará tranquilo hasta
que se haga justicia
obama obama y biden dejaron que corea
del norte amenazara a eeuu el presidente
trump rechazó esa debilidad y aplicamos
las sanciones más fuertes de la historia
a corea del norte
obama y biden dejaron que irán se
saliera con las suyas y literalmente les
enviaron un avión lleno de dinero
el presidente trump hizo lo correcto y
rompió el acuerdo nuclear con irán
joe biden es bueno para irán y el estado
islámico increíble para la china
comunista
la última vez el jefe de joe fue obama
esta vez será pelosi sanders y la
pandilla su visión para eeuu es
socialismo y sabemos que el socialismo
ha fallado en todos lados
bardem también quiere traer más
inmigrantes ilegales para quitarles los
trabajos a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses su política de fronteras
abiertas arrastrará los trabajos hacia
abajo para los estadounidenses en un
tiempo en el que los trabajadores de
bajos ingresos tendrán un aumento real
por primera vez en la historia moderna
para los radicales demócratas este país
es la fuente de los problemas
porque creen que el único camino es
borrar la historia de acabar con el
pasado y destruir los monumentos de
nuestros padres quieren no respetar la
bandera quieren quemar esta bandera que
representa el patriotismo y el sueño
estadounidense quieren y respetar el
himno arrodillándose
no importa donde vivas tu familia no
estará a salvo en el eeuu de los
demócratas radicales pero aún queda
mucho trabajo por hacer si amas a eeuu
si quieres que avance
donald tram es tu presidente él es mi
presidente y me siento orgulloso de
llamarlo amigo
[Música]